that Dolores man Wow she is she's a
piece of work I was once and they said
oh by the way guess who you are oh can I
say that they thought you were Angela
they thought you were Teddy I thought
you were a samurai then no one knew but
we did welcome to the end of the game at
the end of 3 or 4 we discovered there's
not just one Delores pearl there are
multiple there's at least four out there
what was your reaction when you
discovered that twist and once fans have
seen that episode what do you want to
say to them I think we realized it was
all Dolores it was kind of an of course
mullet yeah you know that's the classic
Westworld move if they want you to think
it's all these other things and they
want to you know take you down a rabbit
hole that is just gonna lead nowhere and
of course I mean she's the most advanced
one of them so why wouldn't she just
duplicate herself multiple times I know
you down to your bones
it's amusing that you think you chose to
kill your own daughter you don't even
have a choice in your own grave are you
your oldest friend they didn't tell me
until right before like what like I
didn't know until maybe like the day
before that I was you but you were
inside my body yeah and then I remember
I probably panicked didn't text you
that's like Kenny what can you tell me
things why are they giving in season two
we both were an agreement that she was
just gonna die and I was like ready to
be impaled by you I was just like that
was my mystery I was like how am I gonna
die cuz you were the same person and
this is gonna go on forever well let's
talk specifically about three oh three
because at this point the audience is
gonna be trying to figure out who is
actually inside of Hale's body you as
you were playing it did you ever think
you were Teddy no no no no I never
thought I never felt Teddy inside my
bones okay
Oh mm-hmm-hmm no no I mused about it a
little at the beginning but like yeah
yeah yeah that's true I think they told
us didn't they tell us right away but we
couldn't tell anybody else yeah we knew
pretty early on yes we needed to know
how to interact with one another
exactly so but it's fun for everyone
else to speculate like everybody like
the crew cast everybody who didn't know
everyone kept noting new and that was
fun they thought you were Angela I
thought you were Teddy yeah you were a
samurai than no one knew but we did and
then were there any little nuances of
Dolores
that you imparted into Tessa a few
little Easter eggs that I had developed
in the first couple seasons like hand
placements and things with the voice and
but for the most part yeah and then
every now and then I I would record
dialogue and then she was really
generous she'd send me boys animals
someday like the night before I do think
can you send me this speech I I could
eBay them yeah I mean I have like hot to
look never-before-heard Westworld to
learn bird voice memos which i could
auction for charity this is true but
then she did such an amazing job of
marrying the two characters together and
really giving this version of her a life
of their own because there may be a
different version of her but this is
still a separate being and with its own
thoughts and its own wants and desires
and so it was interesting to see how
they evolved in different ways the other
poems
I assumed you brought someone else
you've just made copies of yourself
if you want something done right do it
yourself
I shouldn't have to explain that to you
me let's take a look at 3:04 when Maeve
discovers that Delores actually
duplicated her pearls and put them into
a number of hosts Tandy when did you
first find out that that was the case
when I discovered that Musashi wasn't
Musashi I mean I loved here here oh he's
a friend and I admire him so so much and
the that those episodes in Shogun world
they were really profound and meaningful
both on and off screen you know amazing
imagine learning to use a guitar and
speaking Japanese so to suddenly
discover that he has been used to to
destroy me it was so God it was like a
hot betrayal it was tragic I really felt
it was a brilliant idea it's such a
great idea that Delores man Wow
she is she's a piece of work oh yeah
when I read the script it was a great
idea you know no more some write the
same body but female inside and then
fight against somebody
it was so excited it's so interesting so
I really enjoyed the shooting we also
everything changed the way you carried
yourself on set and played the role it
was a unique balance you know I have
memory as a Musashi
as a samurai the last life for my body
but also I have different you know
personality inside but it's it's mixing
not one side so that's that kind of
balance was so difficult and also very
interesting for me it social you try and
stop me
I'd have surprised Menard
after all the time we spent together it
don't recognize your only friend
hello Dolores you look very nice don't
we tell me when did you find out that
twist Deena happens I was once and I
said oh by the way guess who you are I
thought oh great so then I tried to do
Dolores as mana isms and stuff I'm
whispering here but yeah they said it
was a challenge I didn't give you any
tips
she was so everyone so kill we cannot
try to do something but it was all so
last-minute
I just found myself a bit confused but
hopefully we pulled it off
looking ahead after that episode what do
you want to tease to the fans out there
now that you are someone completely
different it's kind of hard to kill the
robots isn't it so I see
[Music]